[Musique]
avec human aubeterre clément daquin
s'interroge sur la répétition du
mouvement sur l'engagement physique au
travail
il raconte à travers le jonglage un art
qu'il a choisi de partager avec un de
ces artistes de plateau avec la main
comme si elle à l arrivée pour
l'initiation on a fait un peu de
foulards pour apprendre à jongler à
trois foulards on a fait un peu de
déquilibre d'objets ça veut dire
apprendre à tenir un objet en équilibre
donc là on a fait des plumes de pense
que c'est assez simple détente lie au
jonglage et et
s'amuser sa musique comme ça dans cette
discipline initier des gens qui
connaissent pas du tout cet atelier
s'inscrit dans une nouveauté celle des
brunchs créatif lancé cette saison par
la salle du prisme
ça fait partie des choses qui sont
importantes dans un théâtre il faut être
en mouvement il faut imaginer de
nouveaux moyens pour aller à la
rencontre des publics en douce et ont
des changes de partage et de
convivialité pour sortir un petit peu du
rapport traditionnel du spectacle de
rencontrer aussitôt de personnes ça
quand on vient un spectacle c'est pas
toujours le moment propice pour échanger
avec son voisin de fauteuils voilà
pendant la la représentation la la c'est
le propos c'est de créer recréer du lien
et du coup là le poignet plus tôt ouais
plutôt comme ça
un autre rendez vous est prévu pour le
mois de mai avant de devenir trimestriel
la saison prochaine
[Musique]